[Music]
what's up Wolfgang we just got a new
ant-man and the wasp trailer and I'm
really excited for the movie to come out
especially after this trailer I think it
is much better than the first one that
we've seen in this video I'll be talking
about what you need to know that was
shown in this trailer for ant-man and
the wasp before we get started just a
reminder about our giveaway that we're
doing all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel subscribe to the
stupendous wave give this video a like
and give it a comment below with your
favorite superhero that could be Marvel
DC or otherwise for your chance to win a
full speaker system so here's the new
trailer for an again no I just sort of
happened like bad guys like you
[Music]
and I seem to mess it up almost every
time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watch for
back
like a partner
[Music]
back pain I actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum realm
that's when he's crazy could be ghostly
like walks through walls and stuff so
Leo tech and now supposed to take over
the world or whatever who would have
believed that in your hour of need you
would turn the house about me Rob do you
do you remember that's us feeling chess
we practiced this poker game
and man in the wasp teaming up follow my
lead
[Music]
she seems more intense
[Music]
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
[Music]
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny I
was partners with Hank on a project
called Goliath how big did you get my
record 21 feet
you've 65 feet 65 if you two are
finished comparing sizes 65 okay so this
first scene is Scott Lane
talking to his daughter she asks him how
long have you been ant-man for and he
replies it sort of just happened we
learned from Avengers infinity war that
Scott Lang and Clint Barton took a plea
deal so they could go back and be with
their families and they're supposed to
be on house arrest right now so it's
probably safe to assume that Scott Lang
is not supposed to be doing anything as
the ant-man while on house arrest but
apparently it seems like there was some
sort of situation where Scott Lang had
to put on the ant-man suit and become
ant-man to save some sort of situation
the next scenes are really trying to set
up the wasp as Scott continues to talk
to his daughter he says I seem to mess
it up every time they then show a scene
of him trying to save the day in a
rather chaotic fashion it's safe to say
that ant-man isn't the most graceful
superhero as he continues to talk to his
daughter she says maybe you just need
somebody watching your back like a
partner then they should the wasp going
ham on some people and might I add very
gracefully she's a little less rough
around the edges than ant-man is the
next scene is Lois talking to dr. Pym
and two things are very important that
he says here the first thing is he opens
up the quantum room it's been said that
they're really going to explore the
quantum realm in ant-man on the wasp and
I believe that this is going to play a
huge part in Avengers 4 so when you go
watch the movie be on the lookout for
anything that could contribute to
adventures 4 and then he says then
there's this crazy creepy ghost who can
walk through walls stole dr. pimps tech
if you're not familiar with who the
crazy creepy ghost character is the
character is actually ghost that's right
the character's name in the comics is
ghost but it's actually not from ant-man
and the loss ghost this actually from
Iron Man
I won't talk too much about ghosts
because I'll be doing a whole separate
video about ghosts later but there are a
few things you should know so to start
off in the comics ghost is actually a
man but we clearly see here in the
trailers that ghost is a woman I'm not
sure if they did that for any
significant reason rather than just to
do it so it looks like well I have to
just wait till the movie comes out to
see about that another thing is you hear
Luis when he's talking to hank pym say
that she wants to take over the world or
something this is a little different
from the comics and the comics ghost
tries to take down oppressive corporate
empires by using a combination of elite
hacking skills and phasing abilities
that the suits give her so my guess is
that in this movie she's going to be
trying to take down hank pym somehow and
real fast on her abilities like it says
in the trailer she can walk through
walls and she can also turn invisible
the rest of the trailer is pretty much
just really cool action scenes but there
is a really quick clip of ant-man into
quantum realm again it's been said that
there's going to be a big importance
about the quantum realm and ant-man on
the watch so pay attention when you see
the movie and the last scene that you
really need to know about is at the end
of the trailer they introduced to us
Bill Foster Bill Foster started out in
the comics as a lab assistant to Hank
Pym eventually he goes out on his own
and develops his own version of the Pym
particle formula and becomes the hero
black Goliath fun fact about Goliath is
that he was actually with the Avengers
for a short period of time and he fought
in Avengers Civil War he was on the side
of Captain America and he was the first
person to die in the comic series that's
it for this video on ant-man and the
wasp it comes to theaters July 6 so be
sure to go and see it it really does
look a lot better than the first ant-man
and I'm really excited to actually see
this movie let me know what you guys
think of the characters and if you're
excited to see the movie in the comments
below also don't forget about our
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel and join the
wolf gang subscribe to the stupendous
wave give this video a like and drop a
comment below with your favorite
superhero Marvel DC or otherwise for
your chance to win a full speaker system
thank you so much for watching woof woof
you